Oh
zoom loud it's charity event we're
getting the band back together for we're
going to play rock band up on stage san
Francisco's DNA lounge and anybody can
come anybody can come and bring a band
and rock out on stage gonna raise a
bunch of money we're getting back
together Froome I mean we haven't
headline to show and we will never
headlined the show but um this is for
the kids it's for child's play and I'm
all about the kids so we are we're
reuniting finally after a couple of very
hard months I'll biggest hits well say
it ain't so you've heard of that one
right don't stop believin yeah i mean
real we didn't actually write these
songs we downloaded them as soon as they
were available
were we innovative absolutely I mean did
we did we do anything that was new per
se no but we weren't we weren't new to
Batum I guess you would say but we were
innovative we innovated like twice three
times a day for on Sundays just a minute
a good symbolic metaphor for being a
woman in rock band is a so so imagine
that you're surrounded by a bunch of
geeks what's it like working with these
people well um you know like when you
wear like double socks in the winter
goes cold and your feet start sweating
and itches like that we have our
scuffles but I believe we do a good job
at camaraderie Karen red blue green
green green red tell me how to play bass
okay well you were doing red blue bring
bring bring blue yeah I heard it too and
blue is not right sense colorful to be
honest I really don't care about these
people at all I'm really here for the
money it's charity event what what do
you mean charity there's no frakkin
money I am here because I love my
bandmates
you is the right thing
no really for a long time we weren't
even talking to I mean we hated each
other I think at one point we had
restraining orders everybody in the band
had restraining orders out against me
and as well as three of the members of
weezer but that's really another
conversation did did all the guys in the
band fight over Karen you know I feel
like that's a lot of water under the
thing I mean with yeah I don't want to
get into who did what to whom okay who
stabbed who in the kidneys with a
replica final fantasy eight gunblade
were there any addictions yeah we were
really addicted to and it has a lot
of carbs why did we break up it's
because I say we broke up the cuz of
sake seg we had creative differences we
did all kinds of stuff after we after we
broke up and mean geez we got into
progressive rock
there was the time we did the conga
drums you gotta go and somebody actually
did some conducting which I which I
think was a mistake if I could sum up
baby dog time in one word it would be
completely awesome we're gonna have a
blast we're gonna we're gonna rock